From the previous quiz the problem is that the variable i that's used in this
thread creation operation is a globally visible variable that's defined in main.
When its value changes in one thread,
every one of the other threads will see the new value.
In this particular case the second thread that was created in
pthread_create was created with i equal 1.
In the thread function, p will become equivalent to the address of i and myNum
will then become equivalent to the actual value of i, so that's presumably 1.
However, it is possible that before this thread had a chance to
execute these operations and set the value of myNum to be 1,
the main thread went into the next iteration of this for loop.
And there it incremented i.
So i is now 2.
Since we passes an argument the address of i,
p will also correspond to the address of i.
So it will point to the same i and then myNum will actually take as
a value the new value of i so it will take as a value 2.
So it's not like we lost the print out from that second thread that we were
expecting with print out thread number 1, it's just that both the second and
the third thread ended up seeing that the value of i is 2 and
that's why then printing out thread number 2.
We call this situation a data race, or a race condition.
It occurs when one thread tries to read a variable that
another thread is modifying.
In this example the second thread that we created was trying to
read the variable i, and we were expecting it that it would read i equal 1,
however at the same time the main thread was modifying i,
was incrementing it, and it became 2.
To correct the problem let's look at a slightly modified code here.
We see that in the for
looping main the value of i is first copied into an array.
Into an element of an array tNum.
The array has s many elements as there are threads and
when we are creating a thread we pass as an argument the address of
the particular element of the array that corresponds to that thread number.
By creating this array then, it's like as if we created local storage, or
private storage, for
the arguments of every single one of the threads that we create.
Now we don't have to worry about the ordering of
how the new threads will execute the operations, because every one of
them will have their own private copy of the input arguments that won't change.